[Musique]
nous allons tous mourir ce soir, je
regardais la télé à la maison et c'était une
interview que je disais, ils vont en
refaire un tas et je me demandais
qui allait toucher à ce pauvre
[ __ ] classique, nous avons trouvé un super  artiste
qui est brillant et c'est Fede Alvarez,
il comprend ce qui fait qu'une histoire fonctionne, je
dois rassembler les pièces
de ce livre, je veux vraiment chaque fois que
je fais quelque chose les choquer d'une manière
comme les provoquer, mais cela doit fonctionner
pour les gens.  qui n'a jamais vu l'
original, cela m'est attaché en tant qu'âme,
nous allons devoir la tuer,
ce que nous avons essayé de faire dans cette histoire, c'était d'
essayer de trouver ces nouvelles idées, je peux
vous choquer mais d'une manière différente, je suis
vraiment excité de le faire.  voir quelque chose qui me
tient vraiment à cœur renaître par
un grand artiste,
c'est fidèle à l'esprit original mais
il a vraiment sa propre voix, sa propre
intensité et c'est scandaleux, tout comme
le premier, c'était
toi